des négociations difficiles mais qui ont
finalement abouti
les dirigeants européens sont tombés
d'accord pour sanctionner le pouvoir dit
le russe à cause de la répression menée
contre les opposants
mais le président loukachenko n'est pas
visée par ces mesures
tom cruise est de passer par la
procédure écrite nous mettrons en oeuvre
vendredi les sanctions à l'encontre de
la biélorussie et vous savez que ce qui
est sur la table est une liste d'environ
40 non à propos de monsieur loukachenko
non monsieur lukashenko ne figure pas
sur la liste actuelle mais bien sûr nous
suivrons la situation nous suivrons les
développements vous savez que nous
sommes en faveur d'un dialogue inclusif
sur la biélorussie à ces sanctions
européennes s'ajoute celle des états
unis
washington annonce des sanctions
économiques à l'encontre de huy ou
responsables biélorusses dont le
ministre de l'intérieur en représailles
minsk a annoncé le rappel pour
consultations de ses ambassadeurs en
pologne et en lituanie deux pays
soutenant activement l'opposition la
biélorussie a également annoncé des
sanctions contre lui par la décision
adoptée aujourd'hui l'union européenne
s'est aliéné de son voisin la
biélorussie c'est également un fait est
qu'un quart de siècle n'a pas suffi à
l'union européenne pour mettre en oeuvre
l'accord de partenariat et de
coopération avec la biélorussie mais
seulement quelques semaines ont suffi
pour imposer des sanctions
ce compromis européen était réclamée par
chypre nicosie bloqué jusqu'à présent
toutes sanctions contre minsk temps que
bruxelles ne durcisse est pas sa
position envers ankara la turquie est
accusé de vouloir mettre la main sur des
gisements d'hydrocarbures situés dans
les eaux territoriales chypriotes et
grecs
après cette décision les autorités
turques ont rejeté la menace de
sanctions européennes
recep tayyip erdogan avait déjà appelé
au respect des droits de son pays
malgré ces tensions diplomatiques ankara
et l'union européenne assure vouloir
améliorer leurs relations
bruxelles a notamment proposé la turquie
de développer la coopération dans
certains domaines et de relancer les
discussions sur la modernisation de
l'union douanière
en retour les turcs doivent s'engager à
cesser leurs forages dans les eaux
grecques et chypriotes